president biden will be celebrating the
passage of his infrastructure bill this
afternoon but as skyler henry reports an
even bigger social spending plan remains
an uphill battle for the president
president biden will sign his more than
one trillion dollar infrastructure bill
into law this afternoon today i'm signed
and i'll certainly sign a bipartisan
infrastructure deal
everyone knows we're long overdue to
make major investments in infrastructure
the bill includes billions for physical
infrastructure such as america's roads
and bridges and public transportation it
also modernizes and expands the
broadband infrastructure and includes 55
billion dollars in clean water
investments we can't stop there
we need congress to pass my bill back
better plan as well the president has
picked former new orleans mayor mitch
landrieu to be in charge of coordinating
where and how the money is spent polls
show that the infrastructure bill is
very popular with the american people
but the president's own popularity is at
an all-time low as inflation takes hold
in the country when gas rises
average is now
over three dollars a gallon and some
places quite a bit higher americans
notice it and it it makes it makes a
difference white house advisors say
passing the president's nearly two
trillion dollar buildback better plan
will actually help lower inflation it
makes these investments while actually
offsetting them by increasing taxes on
corporations and wealthy individuals
massive tax and spending bill which is
going to harm american families people
are going to pay higher prices they're
going to be higher taxes and of course
we're going to see an increase in the
debt the house is expected to vote on
the plan this week schuyler henry cbs
news the white house
president biden will hit the road this
week with stops in new hampshire
tomorrow in michigan on wednesday to
sell the benefits of the new
infrastructure plan to the public